hey everyone happy monday and today we
are talking about pokemon legends
archaeos not exactly being a fully open
world a fortnight movie that is being
considered and how the diablo ii
resurrected servers are still struggling
two weeks later i'm persia and this is
your gamespot news
ever since the reveal of pokemon legends
arches fans have taken note of the
similarities between it and the legend
of zelda breath of the wild with many
assuming the upcoming pokemon title
would borrow the latter game's open
world exploration that is not the case
with the pokemon company now
definitively confirming how exploration
in the world of pokemon legends archaeas
will work in a statement to kotaku the
pokemon company states that players set
out from a central hub village before
accepting missions and venturing forth
into different open areas of the hisui
region they'll then return to the
village when their task is complete that
makes pokemon legends rks sound less
like a pokemon version of breath of the
wild and closer to capcom's monster
hunter series which also has players
departing a central hub to venture out
to specific regions of the world for
hunts players will be able to set up a
base camp once within a specific region
and it doesn't seem as if they'll be
able to walk to another region of the
map on foot without first specifically
departing for that region from the
jubilee village pokemon legends rks is
currently slated to release january 28th
of 2022 for the nintendo switch
all right fortnite fans the game might
not be available on ios or the google
play store but epic games is considering
a fortnight movie that report comes via
tech outlet the information which added
that a trio of former lucasfilm
employees have joined epic games this
year and a fortnight movie has as you'd
expect already been discussed the
project is entirely theoretical right
now but if fortnite's pension for a
crossover continues into hollywood the
possibilities would appear to be
limitless as the game already pulls from
some of the world's biggest brands like
marvel nfl and star wars then again a
fortnight movie may be a good time to
expand on fortnite's original characters
and lore which already serve up a
constant stream of new heroes monsters
and space-time mysteries each season
epic is reportedly weighing in the
merits of such an endeavor due in prior
to fortnite's absence from ios which
will cost the company an exorbitant
amount of money especially as apple has
already clarified that fortnite will
remain off the store until all legal
appeals are settled which could take up
to five years but if a fortnight movie
does happen to come to life what would
be your all-star cast let me know in the
comments below
despite having launched over two weeks
ago diablo ii resurrected is still
suffering from many of the same login
issues with the game even going offline
for multiple hours over the weekend for
emergency maintenance even with the
maintenance the issues were still
persisting blizzard's north american
customer support twitter account has
almost exclusively tweeted about
diabetes related issues from october 9th
to 11th with reports of login problems
due to the game's authentication servers
but fixes are actively in the works
blizzard says that players should start
to see improvements in these issues as
of this afternoon so if you've happened
to find yourself struggling to log in
over the past few weeks well maybe
there's a little hope on the horizon
good luck
it's been in early access but don't
forget back for blood is releasing
everywhere tomorrow october has been
full of spooky games and i want to know
which other ones you're looking forward
to this month let me know in the
comments below and of course please
leave that like subscribe and don't miss
your next gamespot news update thanks
for watching
you